we got to see a little John Cena heart
oh in this movie
I mean great I mean really like the
majority it was you know you and will be
yeah like you that was really you I
thought it was great to get to kind of
flip it in a in a franchise like this
it was really cool to be able to enter
as Jacob as you saw him in nine doing
what he does and then
evolve into a cool uncle but it made
sense like hey we need to we need to get
to get him a to B and in doing so you
know keep them okay make it fun all
right this is what we'll do and this is
how we'll do it and it wasn't it's not
like an Abrupt about face it's a it's a
realistic character stretch that allows
him
to become instead of tactical blue gear
Jacob to become cool Uncle Jacob yeah
board shorts
didn't you I was dying the shoes were a
dorky too
you went full up you gotta go there and
recognize this game I want to talk about
the female star power in this film and
what it means like number one the
Elevate this franchise and how does it
how does being a part of this like
injecting that tough female energy into
this how does that make you feel oh I
love it I I love that from the very very
beginning
the female characters were strong or
badass you don't start it yeah
I'm very proud of and
passing the Baton and adding more power
to it but it's it's really cool
especially with the addition of Brie and
Moreno it's very cool and you really got
to do it this time oh yeah you really
got to kick butt
now I want one for every single film
because it's just so much fun
you know we'd already be there if Roman
wasn't driving four knocks on wheels
shining baby the success of the films
are no secret Jonathan I love the
franchise so much but one of the things
I think that still kind of makes me a
little is I do feel like people still
consider these like male films but
they're for everybody I mean when you
think about just the energy that they
bring talk about the fact that these
films are just for everyone I think that
speaks to fast Global appeal uh the fact
that it is for everyone the film travels
the world it transcends language you
know you can watch it and kind of know
what's going on yeah like
it really speaks volumes to why everyone
loves it and why the movies are such a
global success a perspective is that
they could be fueled by a bit of
machismo but I'd volley that with the
amount of audiences that it's
entertained through 10 movies now over
20 years so the fact that it can go
anywhere in the world and can attain
entertain such a wide scope of audience
it's not
with the data it's not just guys going
to the movies it's everybody we'd be
nothing without you
and we appreciate you very much can we
talk about Vin's Infamous video messages
that he did like first of all do you
guys get the ones personally during the
holidays to do you get them like on your
personal phones or
does he do that
I'll tell you honesty is a as a friend
he's great at staying in touch and
whether that's through text or through
video message or send me moments
man do I feel loved and wanted and part
of something oh I love that that's like
all the time that's not just on holiday
these
he's very good with letting you know
what standing you're in how he's feeling
asking you how you're doing he's a he's
a real friend yeah it's it you know the
Guardians cast told us that too that
he's very much that guy we have a big
dinner tonight and then also is
notorious for for doing toasts and then
for having everyone else do a test so
I'm getting mine ready I was gonna say
do you have it I don't have it yet but
it's gonna get there maybe after a
tequila because honestly I mean this
film sets up in what we've all been told
is that you guys are getting ready to
say goodbye
is it a little Bittersweet being
together I think it would be too
difficult to be in that mindset for the
next
couple of years because it will take a
couple of years to wind down so yeah not
yet everybody though is together I mean
and I know you guys feel like maybe you
don't even have to say I know you guys
feel like a family and I know you do too
even though this is just you know your
second film is it tough for you to think
about like this iconic franchise coming
to an end I still have a perspective
I was asked to play for the
yeah that's what
a favorite sequence in this film
oh that's hard I would say action-wise
the very end
uh and
Charlie's in the show
I'd stay down if I was you you'll need
to hit me harder for that that's also
really good too
no I'm here no I don't I can't have it
okay
let's break it down to genre no I think
it's there's surprise there's great
action there's you can laugh it's fun
man it's a great movie I did not think
that anything could top seven for me I
mean that has been my favorite but yeah
y'all did like this when I tell you I'm
like what am I watching what is
happening here where did Jason Momoa go
for this like what is what yeah all
right dorks what are we blowing up what
the Vatican wow you guys are going to
hell when you were on set and you're
watching this man work and the stuff
that he's pulling out of that out of his
hat and doing with this character were
you like what's happening here too I'm
I'm speaking for him at this point but I
think being brought into a franchise
that is very self-aware and kind of give
him the green light to be the root of
all evil and encouraging him to go for
it yeah like what a better environment
okay we're all cool here do your best
and go for it his name is Dante I mean
yeah
you kind of got to go there and you
can't be in Rome the city of love
without feeling the love so what was
your favorite part of shooting here
my my stuff was shot in London which is
another place I love to shoot oh that's
right yeah but can I just share
something so embarrassing I landed for
the premiere and
oh wait we did
it it is an amazing backdrop it is again
I think it's
here the first thing you sat said when
you sat down was like
thanks for putting me out it just shows
the grandiose nature of fast bring
everyone to an amazing location to
Premiere this movie that's shot here
that the world is going to enjoy like
that's how that's how fast does it it's
why fast is so big I asked you what your
favorite was your favorite sequence
what's been and we'll go over the whole
franchise all 10 movies the most
ludicrous pun intended ludicrous like
stunt sequins that you've seen or that
you think has happened
mine is the wink the huge wink with the
Fierro in space yeah it's like
loved that what a what a another again a
moment of self-awareness yeah where like
what are they gonna do next go into
space
that is true that is true I thought that
was
that was well done cheeky good
homeboys in space is mine too
yeah I agree and like everything fast
like
like dust real enough to be like
just real enough yeah in the movie you
do say in the 90s if you were rolling in
a 5.0 you were the man so in the 90s
what were you rolling in and what were
you rolling in not
uh man I I was rolling in like a
cars all of them beat up old muscle cars
in a Chevy Nova 1970 Chevy Nova for a
while I had a 66 Chevelle oh well that's
a cool car though yeah that was it was a
POS okay I grew up in New England so I
had like the winter beaters I had the uh
like the Chevy Cavalier not the z34
model it was a really base model yeah I
had some really cruddy cars I don't even
think you were you weren't even driving
in the 2000s okay I was gonna say I
don't even think you were driving in the
90s now that I said it yeah
foreign